o clipe só para agradecer à atenas 15 a
10 eletricidade e todos vocês
é esta oportunidade o facto vem falar
daquilo que é o mar é e parece que vamos
ter aqui um momento um tanto frio vamos
falar um sonho um sonho eslavo que é um
sonho kimati mais ou menos com
velocidade que exatamente mulher na arte
da apresentação vai ter umas frases
chave que é o conteúdo que eu trago aqui
e vocês e eu vou falando um cabo da da
expedição à antártida é este sonho ou 38
anos 60 para conseguir realizar
foi difícil mas sempre acreditei nem eu
sabia que um dia eu conseguir brilhar na
área está a subestação está em conseguir
julgar é porque o irmão dela tarde não é
fácil nós não funcionam hoje morreram à
tarde não é assim
em termos de um tempo muito curto com
envio verão da tarde é muito curto
nem sempre a atenção de equipes ou de
ongs para simular na antártida
a via que consegui conciliar tudo pra
cima de antares duro tantos anos
passaram 38 anos até conseguir
concretizar o sonho conseguir 2003 com
alguns apoios mas não foi fácil não foi
fácil
posso dizer que minha vida também não
foi fácil tanto é que quando nós
tínhamos acordado não falar dos sonhos
quanto seu mix fm 103 muito fácil sonhar
acordado às vezes é difícil nos shows
nos dão prazer e que não esconde a
vontade de realizar e com o empenho e e
força
depois tem que acreditar neles
ao ir para a antártida é pensável que
desfrutar toda queimar toda aquela fauna
brincar com os pinguins focas mulher com
os bóias
eu queria ir a andar de desfrutar o
a cirurgia na antártida mas trazer
alguma coisa de importante dar vida e
facto o que encontrava pessoas que vivem
na antártida
praticamente todo ano a gente tenha
consciência e temos a idéia exata do que
está a passar com o nosso planeta e
algumas das frases que passam exatamente
relembrar e vocês que são jovens sobre o
facto de eu e quem nós acreditamos e
recebemos só continuidade do estudo
deste planeta e e em vocês nós não
estamos e vamos dizer que a antártida pp
pede ajuda pede ajuda à tarde é uma
espécie de barômetro do planeta
diz-nos de pessoas no planeta terra há
muitos anos a esta parte
mas também desliza o estado atual do
planeta e fax as bases que estão a
trabalhar e principalmente pra vaso
craniana que vimos uma argentina foi os
ucranianos de cesta básica que vocês vão
ver no no slide foi quem tentou o buraco
do ozono e e exatamente como misturar
com ontem devido ao aquecimento global
da terra e ainda antártida notas nos
noticiários e eu falei com com 11 e
concluiu que com outros estilistas e ao
gil há um dia e menor na antártida
glaciares pinhão alturas enormes no
verão
neste momento são paraíso cardeal
portanto é claro no inverno volta a
jogar tudo mas no verão com quem
consegue subir praias enormes e vocês
vão ter o cuidado de fotografias com
praias enormes e tanto o fátima gerada
não só a cria tentar perceber todos
esses problemas que te ver tanto com o
crescimento global da terra mas também
cria perceber como como pessoa sempre
ligado ao mar e sempre dedicada ao
estudo de fauna marinha é eclipse
exatamente o que o fundo do mar da
antártida nos podem estragar e à tarde
cima vocês têm para não falar dos
mamíferos marinhos que é o melhor para
as suas conhecidas as marinhas estamos a
falar das focas e dos pingüins da
antártida esconde um mundo incrivelmente
fauna
a maior parte dos animais alimentos do
crio vocês sabem que eu crio é uma
espécie de decamerão um caso diferente
que nós temos um grande time mas é um
animal que alimenta com as toda aquela
fauna e fato é que o mar ahomar da
antártida consegue chutar muito plantão
que por sua vez juntos criam e pois tem
toda aquela fauna viva conta a conta
portanto decidiu tanto queria e
ecossistemas cria que idéias alimentares
e e fire é importante perceber que é
grande reserva do nosso planeta
ou seja é que tá mais proteína não só
por ser um carro e nós pedir ser muito
longe de qualquer continente mas
desfilada tomar para se chegar à
antártida passo rumo ao carro
temos um estreito drae que complicado
passar e portanto tem alguma pretensão
simanca países que que não cumprem as
regras não comprei slides e continua e
matava espantar de matar o sindipan
tarde da mata o fox matam aves marinhas
tanto o ser humano e fahel é o bixo mau
deste planeta e já estamos a falar isso
quando fala que acaba tendo nós
minimizar esse ano foi fugiu
muitas vezes as pessoas não têm noção
que agarrou num cigarro e mandou pela
janela do carro e cigarro vai parar o
mar vai para o mato que chove as águas
pluviais são todas realizadas ea viatura
do cigarro vai parar ao mar vai parar ao
mar vai ver que estes números vão morrer
mas o objeto não faz fase ele vai outro
país como e vai ocorrer ou seja as
atenções nos transmitem no dia a dia
fazem com que a antártida eo resto do
planeta possa ficar melhor e esperto nós
nos vende
eu sou cota a equipe até agora sou mais
cotas
é somos muito mal educados não tivemos
os princípios que vocês têm
são vocês vão ensinar isso vocês vão
garantir a sustentabilidade do nosso
planeta por nós já temos vídeos
incríveis e é muito difícil voltar atrás
eu digo isto porque é fácil todos os
anos várias escolhas do lixo no fundo do
mar e e quem surge mais do mar é quem
comanda uma área quem vive do mar são os
pilotos número parte dos peões não
respeitou uma vivem deus mas não
respeita uma e estamos a falar de meriti
eu tenho muitos amigos torcedores mas
sexo e aos sons os maiores predadores
dos nossos do dos oceanos riscados a
você ea uma das mensagens que o trabalho
antártida é vocês vocês têm que ajudar
porque nós velhos já não vamos conseguir
fazer nada
vamos ver na tarde de terça os riscos
riscos que já sabemos se existe um
problema o problema é total
sabe o que isso quer dizer portanto é
normal é não há hospitais também sujeito
a uma pequena clínica que existe no
navio de apoio e tudo isso é supra vuco
o com vontade e com o cuco acreditar num
sonho e concluir conseguiram mergulhar
que vou virar mulher e iceberg que é
fantástico e dá cursos jesus e e edições
fato é difícil descrever é é que nós
podemos ver a fauna é completamente
diferente da nossa muitas vezes pensamos
na tarde em que um terceiro que o
pensava eu pensava exatamente assim que
não têm nada que lhe é é pobre
hoje qualquer jeito nada desistir não o
facto de uns poucos mas encontrei três
espécies de peixe
vocês vão ter afundado ver mas temos de
estar assustado fláquer engaje em termos
de splodge ários expões excluídas em
termos de novembro estamos a falar de
estrelas-do-mar dores us entre os
músicos
temos falado com enchentes de lapas
henrique cima e por isso junta ali muita
falta aqui vocês vão ouvir também a
mulher bastante berti
é temperatura aqui são menos dois graus
e em dois momentos no geral uma pessoa
com gel no congela nós vamos o
equipamento
o equipamento é seco chamas o fato 5
o equipamento que vocês vestem o fato de
neve é por baixo do de um fato que
questão que não deixem entrar água e
esse fato nos possam percussão morrem
não é porque naquelas águas arrastam as
tramas do marcos bittencourt não é não é
uma crise pobre
esses fatos é no nosso plano não pode
ver um ato orgulharam tarde não pode
haver um problema
o problema é que a pode ser fatal com
jardim e estamos tranquilos mas tem um
metal só vocês têm aí do da dimensão e
da dos animais tão diferente que nós
podemos encontrar se á à tarde e mediar
a equipa que o que eu encontrei
foram anos e anos pesquisa foi tentar
influir mãe projetos mas depois já não
ia haver mergulho porque e é complicado
arranjar pessoas loucas por que tem vai
mudar a antártida normalmente visto que
foi fácil dar qualquer outros quero que
todos iguais
um dia mata outra escola e todos temos
vontade de fazer o mesmo e todos
tenhamos um perfil muito preciso e e
quando vimos um passado de todos todos
sonharam irá à tarde a brilhar
todos vieram dar uma volta ao mundo à
vela todos vieram com tudo aquilo que eu
tinha sonhado tentou o chute que nós
achávamos que seria impossível que
alguma vez vi a jogada é completamente
impossível é e nós connect anos quando
acreditamos
acreditamos vivamente naquilo que temos
a sonhar
volto a dizer só os sonhos recordados
nós conseguimos dar a volta ao mundo tem
que dar a volta ao mundo e voltou volta
ao mundo à vela mas à tarde também
estava lá também sim agora volta ao
mundo à vela
mas a ave estava lá e e e antes de
quebrar um sonho e já estou indo alisar
o qual vai ser o próximo e normalmente o
próximo e se preocupa em trio
porque uma das coisas que temos faz é e
alguns fãs chatos bons sonhos é fato ter
um sonho e realizá lo
após realizar sabemos que conseguimos
fazer isso eu vou conseguir o próximo e
e não tinha grandes mas vou descontar 1
assim rapidamente a minha história de
infância e com velocidade era órfã de
pai e mãe meu pai morreu em brilhar no
campeonato dessa menina
minha mãe não ser do que como a doença e
eu um jovem fica aí fiquei sem
possibilidade ou seja fica entregue a
minha avó e uma área não estava em casa
não podia no primeiro lugar mas eu o
orgulho era pra mim eu estar ligado à
maneira 1º importantíssimo e como é que
eu vou ligar ao mar com 15 anos fui
pedir emprego aquário vasco da gama quer
trabalhar que a trabalhar numa coisa
relacionada com o mar
adoro mário sérgio não conseguirá olha o
foco para já vamos ver
nós a mulher com as cópias do papa é que
quero quero quero estava trabalhando
aqui com cuidado não pode não pode não
pode ir trabalhar a equipe que no novo
treinador é um jovem 94 dias é não paga
pode ajudar aqui nos laboratórios o que
é certo é que dois anos depois já estava
a trabalhar o conceito dias com aquário
vasco da gama e expulsaram o wacc
começaram a pagar a alimentação
conquistaram uma pegada julga ações e
província trabalhado com vasta gama e
trabalhando com vasta gama é ter
cumprido o serviço militar obrigatório
depois foi fundar um zelo mar em cascais
depois foi do álbum da banda madeira fez
parte do plantel da equipa de 12
isto era um objetivo que eu tenho na
negra na tarde daquela mulher como foco
eo parkshopping rio pardo ea conhecida
como maior predador do espírito santo o
grupo das focas nível mundial tanto em
foco é mais perigosa dois ou três anos
antes de o ato estava uma senhora
holandesa e belga foi atacada pelo menos
eu entendi já mais casos de pessoas
atacadas foco do rio pardo
estamos a falar de uma boca deixe também
condenou ambos é o meu foco é enorme
e eu só quero perder com os cães nós
aqui escolhemos prius e vou lá fazer
muito tempo e sei que não não não não
não fazem mal nenhum e aqueles com
muitos parece que o espectro de clientes
lá o tornado exatamente nos próximos
dias vamos ver as focas animais todos os
animais só assim todos animais têm o seu
momento e nós temos que saber respeitar
esse momento e esse espaço mulher com
baleias olhar que os pingüins só que a
antártida
para quem gosta de mergulhar e tristeza
que vocês já andaram muito de vocês como
mas que continuaria como pessoa começa a
mulher aqui começar mulher ali e começar
a ver que o começar pelo clube e que
deve ser mais que uma vez que chegar
mais longe mas para chegar mais longe
temos temos temos temos que preservar
aquilo que o facto que quem imensa e que
faz parte de nós que os oceanos e que o
mar e que vai ser o sustento da
humanidade
garantidamente os oceanos você chave a e
riquíssimo e eu ando homens pobres já
pode expandir porque a terra está mais
desbotada e fateh no marão nós podemos
podemos continuar e vivia e continuará a
manter é manter este sonho de de nos
realizarmos vocês viram ali estava com
11 disparos o álbum terá que o usuário é
que os lava vocês na antártida encontram
é pinhais berti gil transparentes e
assim o direito de qualquer um carro a
diesel num cadinho é um cadinho com
milhões de anos porque as últimas
erupções que houve na antártida projeto
está transparente foi aquecido ou seja
só se estiver em água a ferver e pfizer
ainda dentro do do coordenador agu o gil
não vai ficar branco vai ficar
transparente que os denunciaram seja
tavas 41 caso gil que tinha
microorganismos milhões de anos atrás o
irã antártida e trazer a antártida vocês
tá aqui a dizer tanto o espinho incutir
o espírito da equipe
eu fui
speed tinha dois australianos que
completamente doido lembra que os autos
qualquer uma das asas e semana das
falésias e vai reparar as pedras e
atingem quase 200km de um cidadão susto
nenhum perfil engraçadíssimo e em factos
eu não gostava demais estraga o tempo
ainda é controlado antarte sonho por
sonho e deu um livro de um livro
antártida foi um sucesso o evento eu to
não tinham livros pelos estrangeiros no
brasil isso pra vocês e rapidamente ou
nenhum e eu tenho muito para falar sobre
isto é não tem mais precisão se obrigado
a todos